hey guys this is dennis the founder
think era and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of true detective
episode 5 the secret fate of all life
and this comes out it is a circle is a
smash beer canada it this episode comes
off you know last week's like you know
fantastic episode especially you know
the last six minutes hmm this this takes
a different approach now we've slowed
back down kind of its it's the aftermath
of everything and and most under the new
chapter yes it's almost like even though
last week was you know absolutely
fantastic story wise this one changes
the direction that we're going to go in
beautiful even timewise we jump at a
certain point the episode about halfway
through we jump seven years ahead to we
know something happens with them that
breaks our they said they were partners
for seven years in the first episode so
we know that in 2002 something happens
it breaks them apart again we don't get
to see that in this episode but you know
this is a new new times a little bit in
the future get to move a little bit you
know of course go back to the first half
though which is when they get Reggie
LeDoux was the whole thing it which is
great about this this first half is that
here's this big shootout that they've
been crying about this whole time this
shootout all you don't forget about
being in the shootout and when you're
like you know it only happened this one
way yeah we you know we come to learn
that there was no shootout right yeah
that was all made up because they needed
a plausible way to to explain why these
guys were dead right cuz that this this
whole operation was off the books you
know something yeah they had to explain
why he was dead and you know why you no
good reason for they were out there and
I mean it was cooled I mean that the
premise was cool i like you know seeing
McConaughey in slow motion showed up
that rifle you know and but it was great
i mean as soon it kind of knew it was
coming i mean as you saw woody
harrelson's character look into that you
know compartment you know you figure
this is her to walk out all piss i'm
like oh he's gonna shoot like you guys
well yeah he's gonna do anyone see a
dead kid
a one that looks like in a coma it's
barely alive right yeah you're you're
gonna react a certain way you react a
certain way and you kill the Ladue with
no hesitation Lewis let off literally
almost and I do like how before they
went in you know Russell's like no no
heart hit was telling her oh yeah you go
I'll wait here you get back up cuz he
knew he wasn't going to right exactly
yeah cuz there's potential lives at
stake hmm you don't know how long you
know they were saying that that one of
the kids had died just the day before
yeah so had they come in or found this
them out a day earlier they may have
been able safe that one one kid right
right and I think even this episode had
a lot going on but I thought even though
even with the switch the time you know
going out had seven years thought they
did a good job of kind of merging it it
was a lot to take in for one episode
because I mean you get Reggie LeDoux
they get him you think that's the big
bad but of course throughout this whole
season the first half for five episodes
now they've hinted that there being more
murders yeah and what did they get the
right guy and of course Ian McConnaughey
you know later down the road
interviewing a guy who says you know let
me introduce you to the the yellow Kings
I later refer to ya know so did they get
the right guy well that's with
McConaughey's character now that spark
renewed his interest in it and oh and
are we also in the motivations between
the two cops it's not so much these new
murders but about Cole and he is he a
part of them that's why they're on Cole
so much which I guess we can also kind
of see come because he's the obvious guy
like he's the crazy one is he unto them
but I don't think it's him no but I
actually think me cheesy actually to be
honest I'll be upset if it's him yeah I
would want to if they make rust that the
killer I think it was like AI didn't be
a disservice to the show and the fans
cuz just a cheesy twist you know it's
the detective is kind of weird and even
making heart it would just not be in his
character to do it it's gotta be
somebody else ya gotta be someone either
we haven't met before or someone that's
barely in the peripheral view right
because a guy on the day we're reviewing
you know in the lock-up was saying
there's like Reggie was how about like
there's these place for like these rich
guys go and people go to like murder
people and devil worship like somewhere
in the woods like deep in the woods I
mean there's something else more than
just coal or bigger than any you know
there's gotta be some type of group of
people we're all this stuff is going
down yeah we kind of knew too that these
cops were much more interested in rust
right yeah then they were in heart right
just because of the questions in these
last few episodes they're always asking
heart about rust and what he's like and
all this other stuff and it's more when
heart talks about himself and his family
it's always comes from him they don't
run that they're not asking him
questions about himself he though he's
providing that cuz like they would know
like that but they're asking about you
know cola like so what happened with the
breakup like why'd she leave and all
that kind of stuff but yeah it's it's
really good I think they've done a good
job merging these two timelines and
obviously we see that heart you know
Woody Harrelson's character he's not had
the best time trying to like regain his
family but in doing so looks like now
he's losing it again so I mean we still
don't see the wedding ring while he's
being interviewed in 2012 so I'm
assuming 2002 something Bad's gonna
happen with him and his family I mean
slapping his daughter and calling her a
[ __ ] isn't it it's not the best way to
win father of the year even if your girl
in the backseat with two guys it's not
the best way to when Father the Year
yeah you want to do that yeah so the end
so he gets back with his why you know
it's still the show yes still not right
right and I think to with these two
characters it's like what they say with
like firefighters and people who are in
these type of job yes they can't just
sit still no they can't just be like
okay this is my whatever like there's a
reason why they take jobs like a certain
kind of high there's a certain
adrenaline I guess I mean like with the
military and there's a certain
adrenaline that they get from doing
their job right yeah and so they can't
just sit by and like I don't think at
least most cops I don't think cops would
be cops just to sit around be like Oh
everything's okay all right yeah yeah
they want no I think almost like his
regular life is just you know almost too
boring for him yeah and he's looking for
something i don't know he's but he's
obviously losing his family i hope we
get to see it was spicy and rust
uh oh sorry yeah Rose calling Cole
sitting with his girl watching the movie
like like to see especially him in a
normal experience my girl that doesn't
seem possible like just chillin like
he's just so and I'm sure eventually
that's what leads to their breakup right
he's he can't be that way you know woody
and you know his character like tries to
be and you know sometimes even lies to
himself saying is you got to have family
it makes you stable and everything but
at least coal which is weird same
relationship he at least acknowledges
that he knows he's just not a part of
this this circle that the Immortals you
know look upon from eternity they sell
this you know crushing the can his whole
deep philosophy yeah I mean it's losophy
basically that everything that we've
done we're gonna do forever and ever
ever it's just you know just a cycle I
like over yeah so like those girls that
that died are going to die again and so
almost at the point of like why even
bother but at the same time like even
though you know rust is like a
nihilistic a character I don't think
he's completely buys into it totally
because otherwise why would he even do
anything right he he's more serious
about the case and anything anybody else
is I mean he you know it seemed at the
end of the episode going to back to the
school where they already went yeah that
closed down school and looking at all
the figures and all those you know you
know the figures they found where the
with a girl was murdered and you know
what does that mean you know so I think
we know that rust didn't do it because
you see him there looking at all these
things he's trying to figure out what's
going yeah I think that's where he
disappeared off right where you know
like oh he got off the grid where he
goes try to find these people in you
know the detectors think oh he's
murdering people or something like now I
think he's just so obsessed that he
probably right locked himself away with
all this evidence figure stuff out yeah
so I think the next would have three
more episodes or episodes you know I
think we're gonna see how the uncovering
of that I hope that we're gonna see
these guys get together in the present
dick so it's nice to see you know method
McConaughey get up out of his chair and
walk out of the interrogation room just
or whatever there's an office or
something walk out of the room like in
his present day garb you know so i think
the him and what are you gonna team up
again
and also you know are these future
episodes going to still have these
flashbacks or is it all going to be
present day what's up right or you know
because in this context McConaughey's
character rust is gone yeah so there is
no his perspective no after that time
because right heart doesn't really know
what's going you're not gonna see him in
the interview you know in the chair
again do an interview anymore yeah so
yeah where's he going yeah this I think
this episode is gonna be very pivotal in
in how we're gonna perceive the show as
a whole yeah like once it ends we're
gonna co was you know was this episode
that's gonna take this show to new
heights or for some people a
disappointment oh yeah but we won't know
until until the very end see how it all
wraps up I hope it's hope it's worth it
hope it was it i'm looking forward to it
alright guys so that's what we thought
of true detective episode 5 let us know
what you think in post your comments
below on the website pink hero.com or on
our youtube channel think hero pro I'm
gonna check us out on Twitter you know
chat with us about this exciting shochu
detective let us know what you think are
you join it some people really effort
some critics say they're not with that
into it say it's just like another
murder mystery that we've seen several
times before what do you think I think
this is something kind of exciting check
us out at think hyrum i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
face bugs that calm / think hero fans
make sure it's like that page and share
our videos on Twitter and Facebook and
all the other stuff thanks
you